all right everyone bang-bang lunch money
time wall wall street's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get
our lunch money right I'm here with the
beautiful and intelligent plenum era
nova evo is not with us today he's still
alive but he's not here with us don't
forget lunch money is now sponsored by
block five
they've got three products buy and sell
crypto you deposit crypto you can get
into US dollar loans or my favorite
product as an investor in the user is
that you can earn up to eight point six
percent APY on their interest-bearing
account it's basically like if you're
gonna sit in a digital currency why not
earn some interest on part of it do your
own research go check them out
Viacom slash lunch money I should be a
professional and reader I feel like I'm
a good shocked by all the comments the
kind comments and the views and here's
like oh my god are they making fun of me
I was like no they're just being eggs
tell Evo he can come on whenever he
wants he actually could replace you as
the co-host anytime he wants what's up
what's with the first topic okay by the
way hold on stop timeout
why does it look like you're sitting in
a college dorm it looks like you're in a
college dorm matching shirts on I have a
Nike shirt on mine's more athletic than
yours okay let's go okay black t-shirt
people are gonna comment at a dress code
okay it has been a rough quarter for the
US economy but the country plunging into
a pandemic fueled recession yet yet the
stock market is alive and kicking in
fact it's having the best quarter in
more than twenty years how is that
possible because the Federal Reserve
we've talked about a million times on
here there's a dislocation between the
economic reality and the stock market
stock market is being pumped to the moon
by the liquidity of three plus trillion
dollars being injected in
two markets the Federal Reserve is now
one of the largest holders of Treasury
bonds some corporate debt I wouldn't be
surprised if they start buying stocks at
some point they have lost their minds
but is this ever gonna collapse Oh miss
Pulido welcome to the rabbit hole that
is the quadrillion dollar question at
this you think it's gonna collapse well
the big question is can they continue to
pump asset prices while economic data
gets worse here's what I think is
actually the most interesting scenario
that's being set up is we're seeing
coronavirus cases explode across many
states we're now seeing bars and
restaurants that were open get reclosed
by governments and so there is a
scenario where we actually have more
economic pain ahead of us than behind us
and if that occurs the Federal Reserve
got to print more and more money to try
to continue to inflate asset prices that
I don't know if they can do it that
nobody knows we've never seen this
before and so that is the question can
they continue to pump asset prices
regardless of how bad the economy gets
we'll see but it's an election year you
know that they say they're gonna try to
keep that economy appearing to be as
strong as possible because people like
when they can make money they tend to
vote for the incumbent okay but then
okay but how long can they do this for
because well technically they can print
as much money as they want Wow but the
question is what's the impact of doing
that right is there short-term inflation
is there long-term inflation is there a
collapse of the dollar all that stuff's
pretty extreme ramifications but even
more so is if you start to change the
risk reward mechanism in a market
there's big problems also if you start
to basically just pay people money to
stay out of their jobs because they
can't go back to workers you shut down
their companies you're basically doing a
ubi
right and so it's just this really weird
situation but ultimately just comes down
to the Federal Reserve has stepped in
and by the way I will say I've never
said this on the show before
Federal Reserve's job is to manage an
economy try to keep people employed the
actions they've taken if pretty much
done that in the short term there's
horrible medium to long term impact
but what they've done is kind of been
effective in the short term it's just
look should they optimize for something
else
I personally think they should but for
what they're trying to optimize for
they've actually I'm pretty successful
people are out of jobs and my question
is okay once the pandemic is completely
over how many of those jobs are gonna
return yes
so people are definite jobs but more
people would be out of jobs if the
Federal Reserve didn't act right they
didn't do the PP loans all that kind of
stuff and and then your question about
how many jobs are coming back I don't
know but I don't think it's you know I
keep going back to 20% of small
businesses aren't gonna make it through
this if 20% of small businesses don't
make it through that means 10% of jobs
in America will be lost and that means
that we will have a 10% or more
unemployment rate for quite a while
really really sad and you know that's
just the reality that we're facing right
now so want to see sorry I'm kind of
distracted I have you here an article
here a video of Mark Zuckerberg flame
here it's a lot okay ready I'm obviously
drawing all of your attention there
right no cuz I'm actually looking at a
camera but yes Facebook frustrates
advertisers is the boycott over hate
speech kicks off so okay you worked at
Facebook can you explain to us what is
going on with these advertisers more
than 400 brands including coca-cola and
Starbucks are going to vanish from
Facebook on Wednesday which is today
after the failure of last ditch talks to
stop a boycott over hate speech on the
site look you can call it this is
classic mainstream media propaganda how
about this narrative corporations
disagree with free speech and decide not
to advertise on platform that encourages
free speech that's what the media
doesn't want to cover it that way it's
called they're calling it hate speech
okay again it is content that they
disagree with by the way I don't
necessarily agree with the content
either but if you go ask any soldier or
anybody who understands and has
literally spent time
fighting for the freedoms of America and
has seen what happens in other places
freedom of speech is most important when
you disagree with the ideas of somebody
else and so that's ultimately this ends
up coming down to is they don't like
what's being said but the people saying
it have the constitutional right to say
it to play devil's advocate I worked at
fortune I'm aware of some of these
fortune 500 corporations who the last
thing they want to do is get caught in
the middle of some sort of political
controversial situation so I think that
they're just like we're pulling out
whatever like we do not want to be in
the middle of this they're very very not
was there but they are in the middle of
it if they pull out that's the thing is
they're not there all these brands that
are deciding not to advertise their name
is not associated in any form or fashion
with any of this
until they decide to do this and so what
they're doing is they're taking a
political stand that's ultimately what
they're doing and again I don't agree
with most of the the speech that is in
question but I do believe that it is
important for platforms to remain
neutral because here again this goes I
continue to say over and over again if
we apply the same standards that we want
to apply to our politicians to our
mainstream media you will take down
multiple articles a day from the mine
but my point is that people don't want
the standards applied equally what they
want is they want to use the standards
that they are so-called creating to be
applied to people they disagree with so
if for example inciting violence if you
go to the New York Times right now or
Washington Post and you look at some of
the coverage you could make a very
strong argument that it's inciting
violence it is creating divisive miss in
our country so why are we only going to
apply it to some people whether they're
politicians athletes whatever again this
the answer has to be the platforms can't
be put in that situation
okay I just cannot understand why we
live in such a horribly divisive time
where you know it feels hard to have
conversations with people sometimes and
I don't think that it used to be like
that I feel like people had different
political opinions etc and they were
able to kind of live now it's like
people can I mean listen in my opinion
all of these platforms they're just a
mirror of ourselves and we get to see
humanity and we don't like it but again
the second that you start forcing a
private company to be the arbiter of
truth is a bad thing and don't forget
the most important part of all of this
is that the media is attacking a
competitor they don't like to say this
but they are attacking a competitor
Facebook and the New York Times are
competitive this Twitter and Washington
Post are competitors and so now
absolutely absolute competitors and now
we have media companies attacking their
competitors and virtue signaling onto
them
no dangerous world they are not
competitors because a lot of times these
tech company these media companies are
reliant on the tech companies for
distribution to pay the money for
licensing content so it's not entirely
clean again
they are competitors in the arena for
time attention and clicks and now all of
a sudden you have people who are
attacking from one side of that
competition the other ones and so
ultimately what I just think the
solution is super easy the platforms are
platforms it's just like the telephone
company if the telephone company says
I'm knock I don't listen to the calls
I'm not gonna not connect you based on
what you're talking about
so platforms have to be forced to do the
same thing which includes by the way
that means that you've got to let them
just allow all of the content and then
as an individual we can do it but what
we're seeing is things where they're
literally uh YouTube stars who are
getting demonetized
four things they did ten years ago okay
oh but don't you think that if you just
allow the platforms to be platforms
something dangerous gonna happen
remember 4chan 8chan whatever it was
where it was like all these crazy people
were coming together and planning these
crazy things don't you think that
Facebook can become a dangerous place if
and just even legal things so if
somebody's plotting a terrorist attack
right you can obviously stop that but if
somebody is saying something that you
don't like even if it is foul and rude
and ignorant and all that's in racist by
the way and racist you still have to
allow it on the platform because
although we as a society don't like it
it is somebody's constitutional right to
say it
and I don't agree with it but the whole
beauty of the First Amendment is that
you have to allow people to have the
first statement right whether you agree
with them or not and it gets tested most
when you disagree with the people that's
the part I think that ends up getting
like sucked up in this is people confuse
what is illegal with what we don't like
I there's an attack on what we don't
like
not on what's illegal I agree I think no
I just think that people have you know
forgotten that well it's really nuanced
okay alphabets to Google announced
Tuesday that it acquired North an
eight-year-old Amazon backed company
that makes smart classes the value of
the day it was not disclosed but The
Globe and Mail which first reported
Google's interest placed the price it
around 180 million which is less than
the two hundred million the company had
raised so this is very similar to the
Google glass situation that will go
ahead which didn't quite pan out for
them why are you doing this again if you
try this five times and one of them
works it'll pay for the four times it
doesn't work right like it's such a big
opportunity to be the winner of
connected Hardware over your eyes and
google also has made a lot of strides
around contact lens
like glucose monitoring and things like
that so at the end of the day I think
it's just the risk/reward heavily favors
getting in a situation where if you're
though if you're the person who ends up
successfully doing this even if you
tried multiple times and it didn't work
and finally it works it'll pay it you
know pay off in spades and so it's worth
trying every time sorry I think I
disappeared you did all right you ready
discord you were lagging I was lagging
yeah
discord now has a three point five
billion dollar valuation in a hundred
million dollars for a sales pitch
lighter on the gaming I don't know I
mean hold on a second yes they're
basically there they're massive in the
gaming industry they raised 100 million
dollars at a reported valuation of 3.5
million that's huge big valuation I mean
the amount of money raised isn't really
that big given how big they are but
they're definitely huge in gaming and
with software engineers and we know that
communication platforms become super
valuable
can I have a hot take sure I think you
just want to hear my hot take I think
places like discord which yes it's her
gamers but it's also they have these
communities where you can talk about
crazy stuff unfiltered uncensored
whatever I think that this might
actually become the place where people
go to talk like places like this versus
Facebook Instagram all those will super
polish and then you can go to something
like discord and you hear the crap that
you don't hear on Facebook are you a
discord hater no just I'm saying utilize
the world baby three years ago the
company try to boot a number of its most
racist users for their ability to use
the platform to disseminate hate speech
has stubbornly persisted interesting and
it goes into our last conversation
exactly I don't agree with it I wish
they wouldn't do it but it's hard it's
hard to enforce it is not illegal
wit does a harder force because I don't
like Zuckerberg trying to decide but I'm
allowed to say not say like he is not
the United States founding father some
might think you that's some people may
try to take out the founding fathers
next - all right next topic NASA I heard
you nASA has announced its latest batch
of small business grams providing one of
the 300 businesses total 51 million in
early-stage funding the phase one
projects receive up to $125,000 to help
bring new technologies to market so
that's that's cool it is they are grants
for small businesses but I feel like
you're gonna have to like I told this to
my dad he was like yeah you're gonna
probably have to have like where every
penny is gonna go like a complete plan
before you even apply to this what why
should the small businesses have to know
where everybody what if the government
does in the world their money went today
just saying no look this is awesome
anytime that we can get capital and
resources to small businesses and
entrepreneurs small for it the fact that
it's coming from NASA cool but any
doesn't put hands income of the problem
solvers or we can put resources in the
hands of problem solvers I tend to think
that that's a really really good
strategy can we just agree that NASA has
been on a tear recently first they had
Tom Cruise now they have small
businesses yesterday they had a moon
toilet like what are they doing they're
just trying to mint going to space that
old [ __ ] ain't going to space come on
no all right we'll see we'll see
wait when is Jeff Bezos is hearing so I
know if I win my bet I'm not sure but we
could we can look it up okay definitely
gonna wear a suit and tie we'll see all
right all right
okay this is an absurd story that I'm
like fascinated by this French 23 year
old guy named Alex recently raised
$20,000 on aetherium like tokenizing
himself meaning that his investors can
vote on his life choices
what
he's gonna get in trouble why he's
sawing a security and he keeps trying to
argue that it's not a security and I
think that he's gonna get in trouble
with the federal government whoa for
tokenizing himself tokenizing yourselves
fine you can't sell it for money it's a
security the second you do that because
basically it doesn't like the Howey test
would say you're giving somebody money
and then you're relying on them to do
things to create a profit for you to
enjoy the upside but how is he gonna
profit it's basically the people who
bought this thing end up getting a piece
of his future earnings oh yeah okay
trouble he said I tokenize myself and
asked people to vote from my habits to
get some attention as I wanted to do
something in a light funny and
innovative innovative way to raise funds
it's a great way to know your audience
engage them and trigger the discussion I
know this can become a billion dollar
company but it was a fun experience and
my token went up yeah so like okay
talking about performance like you
definitely can't do that with the
security you can't issue a security then
talk about the performance that's why on
every finance podcast they're like you
know none of there's all the disclaimers
and all that kind of stuff so I
unfortunately I think he's gonna get in
trouble by the way I think that this is
cool I think if people want to go do
this like sure they should come up with
some way to do it legally it becomes
much more difficult when you get a piece
of there upside in terms of their future
earnings the whole thing about like you
can vote on what I do you know ain't
nobody telling me what to do so I
wouldn't do it what would you let
investors decide what you do know would
you let me decide I would like to say no
but you basically tell me what to do
every day so except the Sun screen and
the haircut those are my only two I
don't care about anything else okay not
taking that men at home that was made
right there sidestepped it didn't even
bite whatever keep going yellow shimmy
nineteen-year-old plane is sitting in
her college dorm participating on lunch
money today class and doing this instead
a little shimmy no I'm not dancing today
not today now
another time my [ __ ] walk then the lunch
money Cruz never seen my [ __ ] walk
lord have mercy on our souls those that
don't know I don't know if we've ever
told everyone but I end every single
dance competition on the dance floor
with one move I got a nasty [ __ ] walk
and then I pop up and I take my shirt
and I put it over the person's head and
I walk off game over when that happens
it's great really won me right over I'm
going on the dance floor no one's ever
beat me back thanks
ok ready for my joke yeah let's do it I
got two minutes and then I gotta go do
other things
what's up this joke will take three
minutes so why didn't he just look at
the screen for a second is that the joke
haha you're not funny sorry cuz you're
not funny okay try not to laugh just try
see laughs okay like why couldn't the
pony sing a lullaby why couldn't the
pony sing a lullaby cuz it was hilarious
no why she was a little horse like a
little horse
ah I was pretty good you'd have to
explain the drug have you I wasn't funny
but I see you left your your you're
staying yeah
soften up a little bit the drugs are
dumb
but it's bugs you know it was good
alright guys that's it for lunch money
today appreciate you guys watching well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right hopefully Polina will at some
point come back we may have lost her
forever
if so then I'll be your solo host moving
forward talk to guests tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor a
user and if
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
block fire than your army block flies my
second favorite thing in the world
behind Polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoyed plain in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow
and be kind to your friends